également
[Musique]
adios temps en temps
ok bon kiné
on va voir si ça marche
plus tard c'est quoi ce délire
[Musique]
ok là jim écoutez bien ce groupe a
toujours été une famille et la donne
vient de changer
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dominic toretto roule tout
seul tu va tourner le dos à ta famille
je sais que c'est grave mais le lâchez
pas aussi vite c'est notre dernière
chance on va sembler à nouveau notre
famille bref je te garantis une chose
personne n'est prêt pour ça elle est
l'incarnation même du terrorisme high
tech
il y a des milliers de voitures dans
cette ville et là elle me disent tout
maintenant je sais ce que ressentent les
flics qui nous prennent en chasse
alfred
ça craint
l'ong
abu dhabi
cuba nos chemins se sont déjà croisés
d'hommes sans titre en écoute je crois
qu'il est temps de rappeler pourquoi tu
as choisi d'être ici j'ai pas eu le
choix
pour rattraper d'hommes vous aurez
besoin d'un petit coup de main il peut
me dire pourquoi tu peux venir ce buveur
de thé avec sa tête de crapule élevé au
pudding je crois que ces tee shirt trop
moulant ça empêche le sang d'aller au
cerveau tu devras mètres une taille au
dessus vous deux vous allez bosser
ensemble
génial
[Musique]
depuis le temps que j'attends ça on
attend qu
hier mon tour
young ha ha ha
ils ne lâchent jamais la faire
je croyais que ce serait un combat de
rue
dis donc c'est pas le torpille tient le
volant
quoi
des cinglés
[Musique]
trop stylé sur ce coup là oui
je ne sais pas pourquoi tu fais ça mais
je sais une chose c'est que tu m'aimes
fin
ouais ouais les gars
[Musique]